three things I disliked about sawx
number one it's kind of pointless I mean
it takes place on the side so it doesn't
really add a whole lot lorewise number
two it has the prequel problem unless
you've only seen the first saw you
already know who's allowed to Live and
Die in this movie so there's no suspense
and number three there's no B plot every
other saw has some kind of b-plot
outside the main game that usually gives
higher Stakes to the main game but this
didn't have that maybe they were trying
to overcorrect from spal where the whole
movie was basically the B plot but it
would have been nice to have something
to break up the action follow me for
more saw content